on Prime crime Sheriff's Office who's
inside watch her asses John it's a scene
that left officer shocked and saw that
there was some legs on the ground saw
that there was blood I saw that the guy
was missing half his face a race to find
a missing girl any child comes up
missing it pisses me off my first
thoughts were I I mean it was like I was
literally seeing a ghost and the evil
behind it all there is no doubt in my
mind that you are one of the most
dangerous man to ever
walk on this
[Music]
planet hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable True Crime
cases several years ago the nation was
captivated by an unspeakable crime and
kidnapping and what would unfold we're
still trying to
explain
911 what you're hearing is the Frantic
call police received on October 15th
2018 the call originated from the cell
phone of Denise Claus from Baron County
Wisconsin
the Denise Claus 911 call is absolutely
chilling you don't hear a whole lot of
explanation you hear some words but you
mainly hear the chaos that's going on
then there's
quiet
hello officers rush to the home of
Denise her husband James and their
13-year-old daughter
Jamie
Open
Door somebody's down somebody's
Sheriff's Office who's
inside watch our asses
John when authorities arrive just
minutes after the 911 call they find a
gruesome sight we got a dead body in
this
one we got a body in here
too James and Denise Claus are shot dead
dead body right at the front door um
heavy trauma to the face gunshot looks
like a shotgun shell to the face there's
one shell expended shell next to the
body found another one in the in the
bathroom almost directly straight back
from the front door in the bathtub dead
as for Jamie door's been breached we're
missing somebody she's nowhere to be
found we're still missing a gun we're
missing a
lot a widespread search for the missing
teenager ensued with the FBI even
offering a reward of
$225,000 for information leading to
Jim's whereabouts there were search
teams put together there were thousands
of tips rolling in 95% of those tips end
up being nothing canvasing knocking on
doors they did not exhaust one means to
try to find their answer we
statistically know that every hour that
passes in a situation like this where a
child is abducted the chance of finding
them alive goes down two people brutally
murdered and and she was taken from the
house I mean there isn't higher Stakes
than that ever about a week later as
Jaime's parents are laid to rest a
startling development authorities are
alerted to someone breaking into the
claw home the burglar is apprehended and
ided as 32-year-old Kyle janky Annis in
all reality they was her underwear or
something like that and any any child
comes up missing it pisses me off and it
makes me want to go
hunting jeny Anis turns out to not be
the killer just a common criminal who
wanted to steal some things turns out to
be a massive red hering but it drains
very important resources and Manpower at
a time when you can't afford to be
diverted from the intention of the
investigation at the national Center for
missing and exploited children we were
wondering the same thing is jimie out
there is she even alive as the days went
on media tension at least nationally
started to go down we're strategizing
behind the scenes trying to figure out
you know what we could do I had plans to
go out to Wisconsin and see if we could
bring more attention uh to Jaime's case
unfortunately for investigators in the
CLA family with each passing day the
outcome for Jamie is getting worse and
worse dougas County 911 hi I have um a
young lady at my house right now and she
says her name is Jamie Closs on January
10th 2019 over 2 months after the
killings Jamie Claus is suddenly found
alive in Gordon Wisconsin an hour away
from Baron okay have you seen her photo
ma'am yes it is her I 100% think it is
her are okay for 88 days I have stood
before you and said we would work
tirelessly to bring Jamie Claus home
today I can report we have done just
that when we heard the news that Jamie
was found I I can't even describe it to
you what happened at the national Center
it we were stunned it was emotional we
were happy according to the caller
Christ kazis her neighbor jeie Nutter
found Claus she gets on the phone and
explains what what happened so how did
she come up upon your cabin I was
walking my dog and we were almost home
and she was walking towards me crying
saying you got to help me you got to
help me Jim's ability to escape in this
case is is amazing to me I mean all too
often and unfortunately most of the time
we don't have a positive resolution like
this it's really through the resilience
and the courage of the person who's
escaped when I saw her I knew she was in
trouble because I knew she had wherever
she came from she left in a hurry cuz
she just had on um a sweatshirt and
leggings and shoes that were too big for
her it's rare to have somebody found
alive after 48 hours in missing person
cases because the trail dries up very
quickly if you're not able to find
something within that period of time
time and distance works against police
officers so 88 days is incredibly
remarkable
uh my first thoughts were I I basically
went into shock I mean it was like I was
literally seeing a ghost I told Jamie
when she was sitting on my couch
yesterday just said I am so glad to see
you Jamie was able to escape but from
who Jamie do you know when he's going to
come
back he thought he was going to come
back
home who's going to come back Jake
Thomas Patterson a then 21-year-old
ex-marine
after Nutter identifies the suspect
Patterson's quickly located by police
while in his car and immediately says I
did it but when he's thrown in the back
of a cruiser listen to the odd exchange
between him and the officer ah you're no
longer detained you're under arrest now
okay sure for what oh they'll tell you
when they get up to the
offic someone going to turn off my
guy do something with it the other
officer will take care of it for you
it's going to be a little bit of a drive
so if you want to get
comfy think that's
possible on some level he's confused
he's in shock even though he knew this
probably would be the end of how it all
turned out soon after his arrest
Patterson not only admits to police that
he kidnapped Jaimie and murdered her
parents but he voluntarily provides
additional dark details I think Jake
Patterson almost immediately confessed
because because he knew that if Jamie
ever escaped he was done for I mean
there's no debate about what happened
there's no um chance of him trying to
explain this away we would learn he
became infatuated with the 13-year-old
after randomly seeing her getting on a
school bus it seems to me like he had
this thing of wanting to abduct someone
a child and you know this presented the
opportunity for it he he something
clicked in him and it flipped a switch
and that was the
moment through Patterson's admission we
got a clear picture of what was
happening on that 911 phone call by his
own admission I think he was only in
that house for four minutes or so so to
carry out this entire thing that quickly
it tells me that he had an objective he
knew what he was doing he had a purpose
and a focus he needed to kill the father
first cuz that's the biggest threat
you're going to have he actually shot
James through the window Point Blank
before shooting the front door kicking
it down and then trying to find where
Jamie was he ended up busting through
into the bathroom and finding them both
in the tub with a mother trying to
protect her at that point investigators
then realized that Patterson had slipped
through their fingers let's go back to
Deputy John fix's dash cam as he rushes
to the claw home on the night of the
murders notice the car on the left that
was Jake Patterson driving with a stolen
license and Jamie tied up in the trunk
something officers even picked up on at
the time that one car was heading out as
we're coming but they Yi on camera
camera yep car going that way that
maroon car that yielded yeah you're
right I had it at
54 you know we all want to say you know
darn it that he should have been caught
the police were that close but remember
the police had just received a call from
the house that an act of violence was
taking place so their main focus was on
getting to that house as quick as they
could Patterson actually pulls off to
the shoulder to let the police pass
which is what most people do so he
didn't do anything out of the ordinary I
I downloaded the video I still I
couldn't get anything like the
headlights were blocking it and I don't
even know if he even had a front license
plate you know it's just one of those
real unfortunate things that they didn't
have the manpower to dispatch someone
someone to follow or get on that car um
and uh respond to the scene at the same
time when we come back we're going to
get into the details of Jaime's
captivity and we hear from Patterson
himself Mr Patterson not only were you a
danger to the CLA
[Music]
family
but then I shined it again and saw that
there was some legs on the ground saw
that there was blood open the
door and uh said that I saw that the guy
was missing half his
face back on January 10th 2019
13-year-old Jamie Claus stunned the
World by miraculously escaping the home
of Jake Patterson the man who had
murdered her parents in Cold Blood and
held her hostage for months now
Patterson immediately confessed and we
would then gain greater insight into the
kidnapping and his mind what exactly
happened though during Jaime's 88 days
of imprisonment according to Patterson
he kept the girl locked in his cabin at
times forcing her under his bed for
hours with no food water or bathroom
breaks they would play board games watch
TV and would even sleep s in the same
bed friends of his have said during that
time frame they noticed an uptick in his
personality that he was friendly and he
was seemed to be happier um so I think
in his warped mind he was forming a life
together with Jamie and they were going
to I don't know maybe live happily ever
after in this particular case it was
about power and control combined knowing
that he had somebody who was young and
immature that he could have power over
and she could do whatever he wants her
to do
Patterson though never thought Jaimie
would actually try to escape you know
obviously jimie is under this tremendous
fear and he's using that fear in the
beginning to keep her captive he doesn't
have to do much to make her more fearful
of him because of what she witnessed at
her own house that night I think for her
she just kept it together every day she
didn't know when she was going to get
out or if she ever was going to it must
have taken everything inside her to just
take that moment and run I can't even
say enough about how Brave and
courageous she was that
day Patterson claims though despite his
obsession with Jaimie he never sexually
assaulted her it was never about the
sexuality of it I think it was about the
companionship and having somebody that
he can have hold accountable to him
since the district attorney in that area
decided not to prosecute um any charges
that related to behavior of those 88
days they decided not to put Jamie
through any kind of Investigation so we
really won't ever really know what
happened during those 88 days in full
detail Patterson's charg with
intentional homicide kidnapping and
armed burglary as he sat in jail
awaiting trial he stuns the public by
writing a letter to a local reporter
once again providing more answers into
what he was thinking the cops say I
plann this thoroughly and that I said
that they're really good at twisting
your words around put them in different
spots straight up lie little mad about
that trying to cover up their mistakes I
guess this was mostly on impulse I don't
think like a serial killer I think
Patterson writing the letter to the
local reporter was his way of letting
the public know what was happening in
his head it was an atrocious act now
it's his time to say you know what yeah
I did this but for the reason is because
of these issues that he has when asked
what was going through his mind when he
started perpetrating the crime Patterson
said he was angry and didn't want to do
it but the reason I did this is
complicated Patterson ends up not
fighting the charges how do you plead to
that
charge
guilty
guilty I think that he knew he couldn't
beat the Char es and he wanted it over
as soon as possible in his wared mind
again he did voice some concern about
not wanting to put jamy through a trial
he put her through so much right the
horrific things that he did to her and
now he has some kind of feigned concern
you know I'm not a psychologist but I
think that you know some of that might
have been
genuine at Patterson's sentencing it
became a question of whether or not this
man could ever get a chance of parole we
would hear powerful Vic impact
statements but in one of the most
dramatic moments a family attorney reads
a statement from Jamie
Claus I don't want to even see my home
or my stuff because of the memory of
that
night my parents in my home were the
most important things in my life he took
them away from me in a way that will
always leave me with a horrifying memory
but there are some things that Jake
Patterson can never take from me he
can't take my
freedom he thought that he could own me
but he was wrong I was
smarter I watched his routine and I took
back my freedom I will always have my
freedom and he will not her family
members now who are helping raise her
gave her the strength to say that she
will not let this influence the way she
lives the rest of her life that she will
be happy going forward and that he's
going to be in her rearview mirror so I
think it's extremely powerful you know
the fact that he tried to take things
from her and he did take things from her
but he couldn't take away who she was I
I saw it as a very remarkable young
woman then Patterson has some final
words himself I would do like absolutely
anything to take back what I did you
know I I would die I
would do absolutely anything
to
to bring them back
no I don't care about me I
just I'm just so
sorry
that's I think pson apologizing and
crying and tearing up was again another
another manipulation whether or not he
felt terrible about it he said he wanted
to go back in time and he wish he didn't
kill her parents and he wish he wasn't
in that situation well well of course
not he's going to jail for the rest of
his life then it's Judge James baber's
turn and he doesn't hold anything back
your actions and
the
ideas that you had are not
normal they are shockingly not
normal I have no idea what
Rehabilitation could be provided for
you no one suggested any
Rehabilitation because even from your
own side the doctors can't find anything
wrong with you for a judge to use the
harsh language that he did you know
clearly indicates he was horrified by
the events that took place in that house
that night and subsequent to that night
and these crimes rank as the most
heinous and dangerous that I have
seen either here or anywhere else in the
state of
Wisconsin and perhaps the United States
at one point judge babbler read aloud
the words of Patterson but the defendant
wasn't happy she was the first girl I
saw once I had those ideas in my
head Mr Patterson not only were you a
danger to the CLA
family and that was his way of exerting
his last morsel of power in that setting
in order to show the public that again
he is in charge there is no doubt in my
mind that you are one of the most
dangerous men to ever
walk on this planet babbler sentenced
Patterson to two life terms without the
possibility of parole plus an additional
years today was a very important step in
the process of helping Jamie to move
forward we are satisfied with the
outcome and believe that it will give
Jamie some much needed peace of mind as
Jake Patterson spends the rest of his
life Behind Bars wrestling with the
decisions he made he may also have to
wrestle to save his life in video
obtained from the New Mexico Corrections
Department Patterson seen getting into a
physical altercation with another inmate
after he reportedly was harassed for the
crimes he committed against a minor it's
typical when an offender abuses children
there's some kind of
jailhouse code that if they get in
contact with somebody who is
incarcerated for those things they're
going to make it known that that it's
unacceptable and a lot of times those
people end up dead as for Jamie her aunt
and guardian Jennifer Smith says she's
doing good surrounded by loved ones and
is taking life Day by Day Jamie will
very likely have more to say in the
future but we are grateful for you
allowing her to do that on her own terms
I've been involved in in a couple of
recoveries of this type in my career and
I think that in this case uh the
possibility of jimie moving on with her
life is strong she has proved herself to
be a very courageous very remarkable and
very resilient young
lady I just want people to remember that
there are thousands of missing children
out there it's up to us to make sure
we're aware of the missing children in
our community because we could be that
person to help bring that child home at
the time of this taping we just passed
the 2-year anniversary from when jimie
was found and as we look back it's still
hard to make sense of why all this
happened to her and maybe it'll never
make sense but Jaime's Aunt released a
statement on the 2-year Mark encouraging
everyone to never take life for granted
and that that quote you never know what
tomorrow will bring always remember to
take the time to tell your loved ones
you love them and maybe we just leave it
at that that's all we have for you on
Prime crime leave us your comments on
Instagram and Twitter with the hash
Prime crime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
on Prime crime you saw someone yes I
thought it was my
apartment
I'm oh my God I'm sorry it's a police
shooting hard to
[Applause]
imagine a reasonable mistake or murder I
was scared this person apartment was
going to hurt me and I'm so sorry and a
defendant who may not be what she
seems I do believe that she is ret
traumatizing the
family
[Music]
hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable True Crime
cases there are a lot of dangers in the
world and our home is always supposed to
be the place where we're safe but for
one young man it proved to be anything
but one this is Carlo where's your
emergency
on September 6 2018 in Dallas Texas
police officer Amber Guyer returns back
to her apartment complex after a 13-hour
shift but she doesn't go to her unit on
the third floor instead she ends up on
the fourth
floor hi this is um off duty officer um
can I get I need emails um uh I'm in
number
um I miss I'm in off duty officer I
thought it was in my apartment and I
shot a guy thinking that he was thinking
it was my
apartment guer claimed that she
mistakenly thought she entered her
apartment when in reality it was the
home of her 26-year-old neighbor Botham
Jean I think there were signs that uh
should have showed her that she was
going to the wrong place I mean at the
outset when she walks up to the front
door there's a red doorm that is not her
own uh that should have been a signal
not only that but entering into the
apartment it very much looked like any
other bachelor's apartment or what you
would expected a bachelor's apartment to
look like there was an ironing board
that was out there were uh you know
pictures and hangings on the wall uh
that uh presumably did not uh look like
the things in her own
home I thought it was my
apartment I need Ione need
supervisor hey bud hey bud
then there are other subtle signs so the
amount of time that it takes to navigate
from one floor to the other something
usually goes off in your mind it's
taking me a little bit longer than it
normally does and then further you look
at the totality of the mistakes right it
may be all small things but if it's 10
small things at what point do you kind
of wake up and and understand that
you're in the wrong place investigators
would clude that at the time guer
entered the unit Jean was on the couch
eating ice cream evidence would even
suggest that Jan may have been in a
cowering or ducking position when shot
so then why did guer shoot him although
she failed to clearly State this on the
911 call she later said she thought Jean
was an intruder and her life was in
danger I don't believe that she
reasonably perceived a threat here she
entered into an apartment that was not
her own it didn't have the same doormat
uh presumably the affix Ms and and
things on the walls were not like her
own not only that he was not armed maybe
he spoke in a loud voice but of course
that's because she was in his
apartment concealment in cover should
come before firing your weapon when
possible tactically the best thing would
have been to back uh out of the doorway
and try to take cover she had a radio
could have called 911 and so
forth
they she
tired
hurry was this guyer's fault because she
was over tired from a long shift or
because she was distracted the
investigation would show that guer had
been sexting with her partner and
occasional lover officer Martin Rivera
sending messages such as super horny
today and want a touch in fact guer was
on the phone with Rivera as she pulled
into her apartment complex she was
certainly distracted but distracted to a
point where you would enter an apartment
that was the wrong apartment think that
someone's an as salant and kill them
that's quite a leap not to mention she
is an emergency service worker that's
why we give them so much uh praise
because they are constantly working
under extreme conditions where they are
a little bit tired a little bit
distracted but that does not distract
them from doing their job as Guyer
excitedly tries to explain what happen
happened listen carefully to what she
says you saw someone yes I thought it
was my
apartment oh my God I'm sorry guyer's
911 call was very interesting uh she
seemed to be very focused on the
consequence to her okay we have help on
the way I know but I'm I'm going to lose
my job I thought it was my apartment I
thought it was my apartment I could have
one I parked on the third floor okay I
understand no I thought it was my
apartment I thought it was my
apartment of course she continues to
reiterate that she thought it was her
apartment she thought it was her
apartment I think it was some 19 times
she talks about uh parking on the wrong
floor which I don't know how she would
know that if she had just shot someone
seemed to me that she was getting
together uh her excuse uh that she was
going to say to the 911 operator and
whoever else uh to justify the shooting
of Ban Jam oh my God I'm done I didn't
mean to I didn't mean
to I didn't mean to I'm so sorry In
fairness a shooting is a life-altering
event the overwhelming majority of
police officers go through 20 25 years
of service and never fire their weapons
and to shoot your weapon and hit someone
and know that that person is probably
going to expire is a life-altering event
so she certainly did sound a little
panicked uh on the 911 calls however
that's somewhat reasonable towards the
end of the 911 call we hear officers
responding to the crime scene that's
when new pieces of the story come into
Focus I thought they were in my
apartment I thought this was my
floor
[Music]
okay and where where are you at right
now I'm inside the apartment with him
hey come on what's your name I'm Amber
guer Dallas police officer Amber guer
shot and killed her unarmed neighbor
Botham Jean inside his home according to
guer she mistakenly believed Jean was in
as salent in her own apartment as she's
on the phone with 911 dispatch law
enforcement rushed to the scene here the
phone
officers then race into Jean's
[Applause]
apartment while the responding officers
desperately tried but ultimately
couldn't save Jean's life the audio and
video at the time told a lot about what
amber Gyer did or rather didn't do more
than likely she failed to render Aid to
balam John it's just plain and simple
hey bud hey bud
she's not administering any CPR or
anything like that when the officers
arrive there's no blood on her she
hadn't really touched him neither is she
asking for any advice from the 911
officer or are discussing what type of
Medical Aid can be given in order to
save his life hey bud hey bud they're
coming they bud I'm sorry man as a
police officer if someone's injured
whether it's at your hand or the hand of
another it is your responsibility to
render Aid it's the duty and
responsibility of a police officer to
protect the rights of an individual they
are arresting so how could a trained
police officer do this when this
shooting happened the blame didn't just
rest on Guyer Jean's family filed a
lawsuit against the city of Dallas which
at the time of this taping is still
ongoing we learned about the
ratification of Amber Gaga's Behavior by
the Dallas Police Department they
provided her her training her equipment
they retained her as an officer Amber
Gyer was asked a number of questions
about training uh she stated uh under
oath that she did not recall her CPR
training she stated under oath that she
did not recall her deescalation uh
training so there were serious training
issues uh that we think led to the death
of boltim Amber Gyer talked about being
extremely sleepy uh she talked about the
issue isues of uh police officers having
to work excessive overtime hours uh
those are issues that we believe places
the city of Dallas on the hook so it's
very interesting when we look at the
police department they're not
necessarily responsible what could the
police department in and of itself have
done to avoid this situation not much
not much they could require police
officers to leave their firearms at work
uh most police departments do not do
that because the reality is we do in
many cases want police officers to be
able to take action off duty if they see
a crime being
committed the city of Dallas has been
exposed enough to put a significant
pressure on them to want to make this
case go away in terms of the settlement
there would be a lot of explaining to do
but the person we wanted to hear from
the most was the shooter herself it was
the only option that went through my
head I was at home and I ma' will you
answer my questions yes
sir I thought it was
[Music]
my Amber Guyer the former Dallas police
officer who shot Botham Jean to death in
his own apartment was arrested and
ultimately charged with murder during
her 2019 trial the question for the jury
was whether geer's mistakes and actions
were criminal a question that became all
the more complicated when guyger took
the stand and why did you shoot I was
scared he was going to kill
me Amber Geer took the the stand in her
trial and I think that was kind of a
no-brainer quite often we we we don't
want defendants to take the stand in
this case she had to she had to tell her
side of the story because the evidence
was overwhelming I heard moving around
inside my apartment what type of moving
around like w out shuffling someone
walking what did the figure do after you
said let me see your hands he started
coming towards me did you hear anything
as he was walking towards you he there
was a loud yell he was yelling hey hey
hey in an aggressive voice okay the
defenses case was entirely turned on
whether her mistake was reasonable if
her mistake was reasonable then
everything that flowed from the mistake
was just simply that a mistake and it
was EXC
why did you
fire I was
scared I was scared this person was
going to Hur me and I'm so
sorry I'm
sorry whether or not this was an
accident look I just can't see it she
went to this house I saw the door open
the doorm was different the acuits in
the house were different there was a
different person in the house
I I don't see how that is reasonably
perceived as a mistake I kind of didn't
buy it she is a or was a police officer
did somewhat work against her what do we
think of police officers we think of
those are folks who have some type of
heightened sense of awareness and where
they are when the prosecution questioned
gger they tried to show the jury just
how irrational she acted that night you
should have taken a position of cover
and con concealment and God help and
instead you decided to go in yes I did
go in you had a police radio on you
didn't you I did when a law enforcement
officers encounter a circumstance where
they might be confronting somebody in
some type of illegal Behavior such as a
burglary uh you know the idea is not for
them to rush in Rambo style uh and
confront a burglar uh because that puts
them in danger uh that they don't
necessarily need to be it then guer
dropped a bombshell when you pulled that
trigger you intended to kill Mr John he
was the threat yes sir will you answer
my question when you aimed and pulled
the trigger at Mr Jean shooting him in
Center Mass exactly where you are
trained you intended to kill Mr Jean I
didn't I literally my hand went over my
mouth when I heard that I don't think
I've ever heard a police officer
testified that they intended to kill
someone I've heard police officers
testify they have in they intended to
stop the threat they intended to protect
themselves protect someone else police
officers are not trained to
kill how do you feel what you did Mr
John I feel like a terrible
person I feel like a piece of crap I ha
hate it every I hate that I have to live
with this every single day of my life
and I ask God for forgiveness and I hate
myself every single
day she absolutely showed a high level
of remorse it wasn't remorse just
because she was going to go to jail this
was something that she didn't in an
outcome that she didn't
intend I feel like I don't deserve the
chance to be with my family and
friends there wish he was the one with
the gun that killed
me I never wanted to take it in person
life I am so sorry this is amer's
testimony for me uh seemed a little bit
contrived she was very focused uh on
herself um and what was going to happen
to her uh of course there were tears um
that were being shed and you know it's
hard to watch uh someone hurting but it
it wasn't entirely moving for me given
the gravity of the mistake and the life
that she taken we the jury unanimously
find the defendant Amber Gyer guilty of
murder as charged in the indictment no
Outburst I was surprised by the verdict
it is very rare that law enforcement
officers are even charged let alone
convicted I would have to say I was not
surprised by the verdict I did not hear
any reasonable arguments as to the
reasonableness of her mistake
well I think that this case stands for
the proposition that everyone will be
held accountable it doesn't make any
difference what your profession is or
who you are we're going to handle it
appropriately and fairly and we think
that a Dallas County jury did the same
thing the trial itself was dramatic but
what happened at sentencing was
something entirely unexpected quite
frankly I've never seen anything like
the end of this
trial
this is not about hate it's about being
scared
that former Dallas police officer Amber
Gyer was convicted of murdering her
neighbor Botham Jean in his own
apartment after she claimed she
accidentally entered the wrong unit when
it came to sentencing the state
introduced new evidence the racially
charged text message history of Guyer in
one message she arguably pokes fun at
the death of Martin Luther King Jr and
in another criticizes black
officers her text messages reveal that
she's definitely got some issues of bias
or at the very least some type of
insecurity about uh being around and or
working with black people the same jury
that convicted Guyer now had to
determine her sentence which ranged from
5 to 99 years in prison their decision
an assess the defendants punishment at
10 years imprisonment in the Texas
Department of Criminal Justice in
addition the sentence in my mind was a
little lenient the jury uh took some
mercy on her probably because they felt
sympathy for
mgu I think this sentence was
appropriate it goes far beyond prison
her life is changed uh if not ruined I
think that this is going to haunt her uh
we respect the jury
decision uh we had a diverse jury from
across the county they heard all of the
evidence and they made their decision
based on the facts of the case and we
respect that but the surprises wouldn't
stop there after the sentencing Jean's
brother Brandt took the stand and in an
incredible twist he asked for the
Court's permission to give guyger a hug
quite frankly I've never seen anything
like the end of this trial the
sentencing phase I was in shock I was
was in complete shock I believe that
helped them to let them know that they
were forgiving her because so they would
not have to carry that portion of the
pain around with him it's just amazing
that that young man could find that
amount of forgiveness and love in his
heart the best qualities of his brother
was showing through him at that moment
then judge Tammy Kemp followed suit and
not only hugged guer but lent her her
Bible when I saw that initially the
judge giving uh miss guer a hug and and
the Bible I thought it was a little much
but again maybe the the testimony of
Miss Gyer really made a lasting
impression on everyone in that courtroom
I don't think there was any evidence
that showed that she's an inherently bad
person the judge obviously felt that she
was not an evil person and she responded
what I feel was in an appropriate way I
don't have any problems with what the
judge
did at the time of this taping guer has
appealed her case arguing she shouldn't
have been convicted of murder rather her
legal team says she should either
receive an acquittal or a conviction on
the lower charge of criminally negligent
homicide and be
resentenced I don't see her being
successful at all courts don't like to
overturn jury verdicts especially in
this type of case when we talk about
this criminal negligence standard it
means that there was something that one
should have known and they didn't know
I don't see how the charge could be
negligence if she herself on understand
said she intended to kill someone it may
be a dangerous slippery slope for her
you know asking to be resentenced maybe
she gets resentenced to worse I think
the fact that she appeals on those
grounds uh that she believes that this
should be the conviction should be
thrown out is evidence that she is not
repentant uh and that she does not
really feel sorry and it really uh you
know draws some question to the tears
that she shed in trial uh I do believe
that she is
retraumatization the death of Botham
Jean is as heartbreaking as it is scary
and there are a lot of takeaways from
this story but when you think about what
happened at the sentencing a big one for
many is you can forgive but never forget
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime leave us your comments on
Instagram and Twitter with the hash
Prime crime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe